if you can't define the inputs and
outputs that are going to get you what
you want then there's no way to start
right because you don't know what you're
supposed to do so you have to Define it
down to like the most basic first action
it's like if I want to start creating
content then it means I have to post
something whatever the input is you have
to Define what the input is that's going
to get you the output you want now once
you know what that input output is the
next one is why aren't you doing it and
so I think a lot of people are looking
for something that is very hard to find
and then they attribute their lack of
success or lack of action because they
don't have passion or motivation and I
was the same way